[Music]
i will be talking today
about the unreasonable effects of
product science in data science
and for those of you who kind of
don't get a reference it's based on
another
kind of paper that was published about
the unreasonable effectiveness of
machine learning but here we kind of
play on that and we what i'll try to
kind of
walk you through is how important
product sense is
a in kind of what we do so since daniel
already have done a tremendous job
introducing me
um you can kind of skip
i just kind of had a job that
if you folks remember the times that we
used to go to school that weren't
all university of phoenix so that
wasn't time i went to school so today
just to make it kind of a little bit
lighter
and we're going to kind of do this a
myth buster uh
episode um by the way rest in peace
grant imahara and who unfortunately
you know passed away about a week or so
ago and but
we're gonna do kind of um a myth busting
episode
about uh story myths that people believe
around
across data products the first myth
we're going to start with
is that data products are about
displaying data and that myth is kind of
you know um
came to be famous about one of the kind
of most popular analyst products
in the world which is google analytics
and uh let me just kind of
move the screen a little bit so google
analytics is this um
kind of canvas where you know google
vomits a lot of
data points into and they expect you
kind of to figure things out like in
you know you start a business and then
your business uh
will suddenly become extremely
successful because you have
uh you have data right well um
not necessarily because let's see how
this kind of concept applies to
on some other problems that we're trying
to solve
sorry um problems like for example
navigation
so for anyone who ever kind of drove a
car and had to get to a certain point
and probably um the interview that you
you have seen did not look like this
where you got kind of a distribution of
uh at every intersection how many people
have to write how many
people turn left and how many people
kind of continuous straight
but some of you might say well vitaly
you're kind of cheating here because
you're
actually like not displaying the data
like a true data professional
if you like displayed it better then
maybe that would be
um you know kind of an applicable um
way to advise people what to do so here
we go
a pie chart so now you have
a pie chart that you know kind of
conveys the same exact information but
probably
um it's not it's not much better at
actually displaying
really the action that the you know
person needs to take in order to get
wherever they're going we're saying well
maybe that's just kind of
not enough data so maybe we need just a
you know
giant dashboard off all of the
possible and like we actually have not
accounted for weather we haven't account
for tr
traffic pattern and we don't get
historical data so like how do we know
where to go
like now we have this dashboard and we
can you know
apply it now you probably need the tesla
like one of uh
the ones that daniel drives in order to
fit all that screen
but now that you have like a big tesla
vagina screen you can actually get this
dashboard
um there and you can actually look at
that uh
information uh but obviously
kind of hopefully the world came to um a
better conclusion
and they came on this you know system
that we kind of
effectively called gps and
really what gps provides us is
um kind of you know really an actionable
system that guides you
and tells you where to go at every point
you need to make a decision
additional thing that gps adds is if you
can see they
also kind of guide you around like why
they made the decision so they kind of
you know my proposal for
routes they might show you how much time
you're saving by going
down the suggested route they show you
kind of like i said uh
alternatively they show which parts of
the route are optimal and
sub-optimal and so you can also decide
accordingly so there's one thing um
that um you can take from the entire
talk
and this entire kind of a episode of me
buster is
try to kind of design systems that look
more like a gps rather than
google analytics really kind of that's
the gist of it so uh
myth number one data products are about
displaying data hopefully
busted the myth number two is user will
behave
as expected and this i take an example
from a past employer of both
daniels and myself is linkedin and this
is a
for colleague of mine uh who's a data
scientist
who was at this data science at linkedin
currently at soulforce
and as you can see linkedin has this
awesome feature
that says people who viewed that profile
also viewed and for those of you who
ever use it
it actually seems to be a quite um quite
useful feature
and the thinking behind it is well
you know when people look for data
scientists they look for other the
inside they might click on something and
you know these people are probably
connected and really that's a
useful way to display information and
that's a
great product because people tend to
click on
similar profiles and by similar museum
you know
similar in kind of relevance and but
that's not always the case where if we
take um
this lady and we look at her similar
profiles
we find slightly different sort of
relevance
and if you look at and this is like a
real profile and that is kind of
unfortunate
then you might see that the and the
recommendations there
are somewhat let's call it not very
relevant
in the um kind of relevant sense that
probably the people who work at this
product
imagined as you can see there is a
territory account manager
there's a photography intern and the
green bay packers you know there are
field producers
and people who actually have nothing to
do
with kind of you know professional
relevance but
i'm sure you all you can guess what is
the relevance that
made these profiles appear there
and basically the point is like people
just click on
you know images that they like and a lot
of it
and a lot of these clicks kind of are
not releasing with relevance it's more
of a signal that
you know people are bored at home and
trying kind of to spend time by browsing
uh profiles and
so really this is kind of an unfortunate
case where like
these things kind of need to be tested
and really not every action
is representative of um what we want
which drives us kind of to kind of myth
number two which
you know is busted as well users will
not just behave as expected
and really kind of um this is
a continuation of this myth where people
say optimize first click and really what
drives
kind of this this myth is the famous
google page where you know one of the
things that google
searched and really made uh google
and incredible and really kind of the
most powerful uh search and world and
obviously now a trillion dollar
trillion dollar company is the
the way that their relevance algorithm
works and which is not this whole
you know the page rank but also they
actually take into account
uh using a technique called learn to
rank um what people
are searching what people and ended up
clicking and this kind of gave birth to
like
we said um the most kind of powerful
uh popular search engine in the world
and obviously one of the
you know largest companies uh to ever to
ever exist
uh the but as you might know and not
just from
the previous example there are certain
limitations to
you know this uh optimizing for clicks
which
you know as we are all aware in social
media
tends to lead for you know articles that
since then have been coined as clickbait
articles right
you'll never believe and then click to
find out you know
what what is going on another example
you know this baby girl reaction blah
blah blah
and really kind of things
that unfortunately now we haven't you
know an entire media industry that
tries to confuse these articles in order
to
um kind of convince people you know to
buy so they can claim that
um users have seen their ad
displays and that they can basically
charge the advertisers on their platform
um but really kind of this is uh
something that is also important like
you know
there there is a certain thing that we
want to optimize and things
action seems very very a good thing to
optimize for but unfortunately
we have to really dig deeper and
understand what is the actual action and
the actual action
is probably more like people actually
staying and reading the article so how
do we optimize
uh how do we optimize for this how do we
measure it and really
kind of the the lesson of learning is
taking the extra step
and not choosing a kind of a simple
proxy that
ends up optimizing for the wrong thing
and
and another way to do it is also um
so these are two examples of kind of
social media what we call
explicit feedback but unfortunately we
in many many systems we don't have
and kind of um we don't have a negative
feedback
so in the negative feedback in a lot of
system is actually kind of an
implicit feedback like if i you know
don't click on something or i don't like
something or
don't share something it means that this
is probably
um not a great uh not a great article
but
in some cases if you think about systems
like netflix
where you actually rate a movie and you
give something a star
in between one and five that tends to
lead to much better recommendation
system because you actually collect
um explicit feedback which is not just
kind of
um testament by a mission but really
um really kind of the feedback that you
get
is telling you that hey you know that
recommendation or that
sort of machine learning thing was and
not the best one
and so the advice here is if you can try
to add
a mechanism to also add an explicitly
negative feedback
to your products so you can actually
measure
and kind of deliver better
recommendations as opposed to just
applying an implicit bias
so kind of a one share quote
and i actually couldn't find who said it
but left unchecked all optimization
leads to gambling and porn
that's really kind of one way one way to
think about it
so myth number three uh optimized for
clicks
and busted as well so
here is another one which is people like
and i think with
the especially with the cern um
advance in you know kind of deploring
and a lot of the research that has been
conducted in the space
we're starting to kind of develop um you
know more and more
complex uh algorithms and model like for
example
um all the rage now recently on twitter
in the last week or two
is gpt free which is kind of you know
the
the mo the largest model ever produced
that is now
kind of basically will replace all of us
in a matter of months
and we'll you know we'll stop having a
job but until then
i would like to argue that in some cases
uh maybe we can think about this problem
a little bit differently
and i'd like to start with use case
which is a system that we used to have
uh we still sorry have at sulphurs i'm
no longer just with salesforce
which is called social studio which is a
product where brands manage their social
activities
across different channels across
facebook twitter
blog posts and kind of whatever so that
is kind of
how this thing looks like and
really one of the main reasons is
because you have so
so much interaction across multiple
channels and you usually have kind of
customer success
or social kind of media managers
respond to certain kind of inquiries
complaints or
kind of other things that people post on
these
social media and here's an example from
um this gentleman called ed russell that
complained
um on klm that was back when
you know people were allowed to fly but
kids just
got back from amsterdam klm totally
ruined the tree paid three times just
for the same
suitcase scaling was rude and unhelpful
and so on so forth
so the problem with these systems which
is one of the problems that we had to
address back and sulfurs is that we
don't really know who eddie russell is
and you know it might be a very common
name and we um
the eddysol sy is also not very
indicative really in order for klm
to try to tackle this problem they have
to
perform some sort of mapping between the
identity of that person
in on twitter and the identity of that
person
and in the klm system and
these problems as you know someone who's
kind of working on a similar one
uh today part of our my current startup
is these problems are not easy and
really kind of
how a machine learning pipeline might
look like
this is not really the machine learning
that solved
this this is just a kind of a screenshot
i took from the
uber michelangelo post but this is kind
of a kind of accurate depiction
of like what machine learning platforms
um kind of
advanced look like that the einstein uh
sulfur sensor one look uh
very similar and as you can see you have
an offline um
a pipeline you have an online pipeline
you have uh data lakes you have
kafka streams you have feature stores
you have training jobs you have
prediction jobs
you have real-time prediction service
and really in order to
build a reliable system which is this
doesn't even include all of the nlp
module
models that we you will need in order to
solve the problem of kind of mapping
between
a identities across two different
systems
so klm could have kind of built that
system um
but instead they decided to take an
kind of some other approach to the
situation
and really they replied hi thank you for
sharing your story
with us can you share the booking code
via direct message
and really uh while you know
this might kind of um um
really not be as appealing to us uh
people who like to build kind of machine
learning systems
that's not you know as fancy of an
approach it's not automated at all it
requires
you know an extra command but as you can
imagine
this saved a lot a lot of time
and to klm by actually just asking
people for their
you know identity in their own system as
opposed to actually trying to
to build it and this is kind of again
the um
it's a obviously a trivial example but
it illustrates a bigger point
that you should start with kind of if
you think about
mvp like not everything has to be solved
using
using a machine learning model not
everything has to be solved using
um a complex
machine learning model um a former
um colleague of daniels and and maya
antlington
and monica rugadi used to say that her
favorite machine learning algorithm is
division
and because really a lot of the things
that you need to do you can just
get to by taking one number and dividing
it by
another so complex algorithms beat
simple algorithms
this one is busted as well and this is
kind of
um our last one which is you know users
want to configure
uh things for themselves and this is a
comes from
um um also this notion where
people really want to kind of see their
recommendations see
like things and see personalize and they
have um
they have kind of these um
preferences around like exactly that
everything is super tailored
super personalized and kind of a super
everything and they actually like
personalization means different things
to different people so a lot of time
and probably people kind of go the extra
mile
uh in trying to adjust um
adjust many systems to individuals and
really
[Music]
in some cases is just unnecessary
and one of my kind of favorite examples
here is if you look at
google which really kind of the ui there
did not change for the last 20 years
right it's
i'm saying it's just a search box and
without
asking you anything about you somehow
and what they know is like if you um are
you know if you are an engineer in
silicon valley
and you type python you probably will
get
something similar to this where it's a
lot of references
uh to the kind of programming language
well
if you probably have nothing to do you
will get something well i had to
actually type the word snake in order to
kind of
uh explain google that that's what i'm
looking but this is kind of enough i
i i didn't have to go to google
some configuration screen and kind of
teach it that
i'm you know i'm an engineer like in
when i say this i actually want to get a
reference for
engineering it kind of learned it
learned about me and just
gave me give me a there's a much better
kind of this
initial experience and b it actually you
know there
is this escape hatch where if i really
want
um to get um
to get to what um we're kind of
looking is you know i just add um
another word and i said title snake and
then it's pretty clear
uh what i'm kind of looking for at this
at this point
and there's also a cautionary tale there
that you know
it's it doesn't always work because when
we were um when i started linkedin we
still had a search
uh a search engine there where you had
basically kind of four
separate search engines for people
jobs companies and groups and
at some point we kind of also wanted to
kind of
create this more unified experience
where people just search and we will
identify from that examples what is
actually the search
term that they're uh they're looking and
so
in in some cases you know if they're
looking for
a company and like let's say in kind of
google then we know that this is the
name of company so we'll show them
information about the company
but if they want for example um you know
to work at google and
want to see some job openings they can
type kind of google jobs
uh the unfortunate part there while
i think uh he passed away uh already by
that point but still
there were many searches for steve jobs
which unfortunately
led to a job opening some companies
called steve
which again this is also something just
uh to be a little bit aware of
and that's kind of you know where it was
fixed
was fixed later but um that
is kind of just another example but
really kind of
one of my favorite quotes in designing
products at all especially products that
have kind of machine learning or you
know the more modern
cooler term ai in them is that really
any sufficiently
um advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic that's
one of clark's kind of free free laws
and in that case that really the user
would want to configure this is
actually in most cases just also not
true and
really you should avoid off kind of
doing it
so really i think these were all the
myths
that i had for today and this is kind of
a
chef displaying one moment where he was
actually
nice to people because i think it was
the kids
uh show so i guess he had to be nice
but thank you um for kind of listening
to my rambling
[Music]
you